vendredi dernier les derniers candidats
de koh lanta ont été qualifiés pour
l'épreuve des poteaux
cette étape finale pour désigner le
grand vainqueur de l'émission le savait
qu'il n'y a qu'un gagnant dans koh lanta
parmi les trois candidats qui se sont
qualifiés pour l'épreuve finale
on retrouve donc loïc brice et alexandra
alexandra qui est la star de la saison
dernière fille de cette aventure elle
s'est battue comme une warrior depuis le
départ elle agite dans l'épreuve de tir
à l'arc là mais en flèche c'est celle ci
elle appartient alexandra on retiendra
surtout sa capacité à se surpasser dans
les épreuves de confort et quand on la
voit manger on se dit que c'est
peut-être la première fois qu'une
candidate va quitter koh lanta en ayant
pris quelques kilos alexandra la
nourriture grande histoire d'amour
elle mange trop je pense c'est à présent
un pub alexandra une candidate qui
n'hésite pas à user de feintes aussi
lors des épreuves d'orientation comme
vendredi dernier du coin de l'oeil
elle a vu l'analyse et sa couleur et d'y
tourner finement l'attention de lola
aujourd'hui alexandre est vrai remporter
koh lanta avant tout pour ses enfants
donc oui je pense qu'elle confirmera
réponse vendredi prochain alors le
casting de koh lanta est il un succès
koh lanta est ce que c'est un succès
cette année des cherry bomb ça fait
quand même si j'ai vu 3 millions de
téléspectateurs
donc ça fera comme il ya plus d'un an
maintenant aussi ils font la finale en
deux fois
c'est à dire maintenant elle attend deux
fois d'habitude la finale si on en eut
point maintenance en deux fois et
l'année prochaine la finale sera huit
épisodes
oui je pense exactement contraire de toi
tiffany l'ascoma ce que j'aime justement
c'est le côté anti héros anti claude
avec des profils complètement lisse ou
de claude complètement oui mais il est
exceptionnel mais moi ce que j'aime
c'est que justement sont des gens qui me
ressemblent c'est à dire qu'ils sont pas
exceptionnels c'est pas iron man c'est
pas des champions du monde de mma ils
sont juste normaux et moi en tant que
ménagères ça me plaît parce que je
m'identifie je me dis est ce que moi
j'arriverais est-ce que moi j'arriverais
à faire cette épreuve est ce que moi
j'arriverais à me surpasser
est-ce que je vais perdre 15 kilos et ça
ça me plaît maintenant vous a fait
changer d'avis ou d'accord et en plus le
casting des femmes particulièrement je
suis pas une pro casting de femmes je
trouve que les femmes elles sont malines
stratège charismatique drôle sympathique
tout lola évidemment alexandra c'est ma
favorite
les garçons aussi son bien mais je
trouve que c'est un très très beau
casting réussi à lui l'homme à sting
heures quand c'est moi qui produit en
revanche il dit non là on voit que
[Rires]
je sais pas c'est pas aller contre
casting c'est pas un succès pour moi
mais je monte du claude il manque du
terroir voulez que je vous dise la
vérité et je vais vous dire j'avais et
j'ai je connais sylla la saison koh
lanta c'est un jeu toujours pour dire je
suis d'accord avec toi mon récit
d'accord avec moyen de minutes on a un
vrai de vrai parce que là c'était pour
vertbaudet vous ce que vous êtes très
jolie beaucoup créé mon je vous jure et
je dis aux téléspectateurs j'avais vu on
avait vu des images de la de la saison
qui arrive et de koh lanta on avait eu
des échos et c'est vrai que on disait
tout ce que le casting était beaucoup
moins forts que la saison mais si rennes
n'avait connu en mars je suis d'accord
avec toi roulage sont différentes pour
le combat après voilà c'est un énorme
succès et après nous ça nous peut-être
le casting nous plaît mais moi je vois
qu'il plaît mais je pense que vous le
casting ne vous plaît pas parce qu'il ya
pas de grand combattant il ya passé
seriez comme d'habitude mais je te
manque pense que castaldi le côté
attachant des personnages un peu le côté
combat tant qu'on n'a pas vous voyez moi
on dit qu'il ya pas de héros pour moi le
héros de cette saison c'est alex
alexandre pour moi le héros cette saison
c'est raymond on est plutôt parce qu'on
était en train de la critique on est
très très mal jugé on est on a jugé les
apparences et bien figurez-vous que
finalement c'est alexandra c'est une
vraie warriors que ce soit mentalement
physiquement c'est la meilleure et ns a
été libéré
vous voulez que je vous dise pourquoi je
pourrais jamais faire koh lanta pourquoi
c'est pas le poteau qui me fait peur
c'est pas les épreuves les friqués la
salle these pas ne pas manger non
voudrait centrer ses actifs à l'étoile
est freinée par les doubles est ce que
vous me voyez moi et qu'une boussole je
ne coupe pas j'ai jamais compris le
principe de la mousse elle un nom bien
dernière fois il y avait mes enfants il
avait un exercice avec une sole jettons
shana copies achetées comme ça et que
nous sommes ce qu'on m'a alors malade en
sus de la tossée
été bâtie de tomates battu
tourne-à-droite te fais pas chier bah je
vais jeter sur moi je sais les irsc à
vous déplacer jamais rien compris la
boussole non plus et à pékin c'est fou
parce que quand vous vous baladez en
diligence devrait rayer moi j'aime bien
parce que le casting est imprévisible on
ne pourrait pas venir au départ qui
serait là en finale et c'est vrai moi le
principal avantage alors il ya dounia
d'orient qui était complètement à
l'ouest aussi comme moi il est comme moi
sur les orientations elle mais moi la
cour de récréation
je peux rester 8 ans accourt mais je te
leur marche je m'envoie là sans savoir
où je vais pas faire de plus sa part
cherché cherché cherché cherché non ça
c'est dur j'ai l'impression de chercher
un grain de sable dans le sahara
sérieusement c'est même plus une
aiguille dans une meule de foin la
sainte croix si immense et grands tous
ressembler tous ces deux sur max attend
des complications plusieurs chiens
bauchi jeu mieux nulle part bien sûr
j'aime ce style
[ __ ] [ __ ] ça rentre
c'est vraiment dommage
alors y'a valentina qui va arriver dans
un instant avec la patronne des
divertissements pour ses divisions celle
qui rappelle à chaque fois alexandre
arrête d'être amis ou ouais ouais c'est
pour vous dire eh oui oui bonsoir tient
j'étais sûr que vous alliez me demander
j'ai pas levé la main je voulais parler
sur des jantes on trouve autant sur la
forme ils ont un peu du mal à se
renouveler c'est toujours la même
épreuve
et c'est en revanche franchement c'est
la meilleure émission de casting c'est
le meilleur casting de la télé à chaque
saison ils arrivent à créer des nouveaux
héros avec des nouvelles personnalités
et en 20 saisons il ya quand même des
grosses stars qui viennent de koh lanta
moundir il ya dylan ya fred et ses très
belles lunettes aux verres fumés c'est
très calme c'est rose la vérité c'est
rouge fumer un peu ben mouaïa les
violences j'ai maintenant c'est un vrai
succès roi du style j'aime bien
j'entends aujourd'hui c'est le numéro un
dans le stylo
merci quand vous regarderez koh lanta ou
prête à tout lire tu discutes jamais
pour tu n'as jamais dans brouille
c'est toujours à chaque fois tu l as
monaco n'y a rien à faire tourner il est
évidemment qui avec sa chambre où ils
complotent pas assez ya passé avec les
colliers non merci à chaque fois mais la
bande de tp le confort n'est pas de se
tuer lama je mange quelqu'un écoute et
non mais il ya calmez vous les chéris
on va passer tout essayé je pense qu'on
a fait on a fait on a passé sur koh
lanta jours et voir ce qu'on pense
étaient les spectateurs et
téléspectateurs 56% à 16 appelleront à
44 et sans sélection plutôt d'accord
avec vous et ils disent que c'est oui
voilà bah oui bah c'est oui c'est oui
donc c'est oui